welcome back Lauren hey happy New Year
happy New Year it's nice to see you
again yeah I'm super happy to be back
yeah so your last talk was a fascinating
story of your pot smuggling career yes
which
you touched a little bit on your travels
but but you're you're an extensive
traveler you've been all over the world
right yes you showed me your passport it
was it was there was no more room for
any more stamps yeah no room uh I got it
in 2017.
um and since then I have just been
on the go completely I think there was
in 2017 I did like 12 countries
and then the next year I did around 14
or 15 countries
um that's a lot of travel yeah it became
an obsession honestly I think uh
sometimes it's just like an escape
from
maybe from like all the pot dealing
world that I was in
um
but it's just that was my Ultimate Dream
Come True like I still reflect on it
since covid everything slowed down a lot
with my traveling and for everybody
obviously
but
um just the reflecting process that I've
been through in the past two and a half
years
every single day I still think like wow
I can't believe I did that like I still
think of little things because it was an
everyday thing that I was traveling
um I didn't ever have time to reflect it
was just on to the next on to the next
and then covet hit
and then I started remembering
everything and I was just like what the
[__] did I just do that was crazy and
I'm so grateful and it humbled me a lot
so rather than asking you what
continents you've been to what
continents have you not been to just
Antarctica Antarctica
yeah and you're young still you're 20
. I just turned 30. you just turned 30.
okay so you're 30 but you've been there
you've seen each other yeah not
everywhere per se but
um definitely like widespread
um what kind of countries do you like to
travel to like I love Paris in London
and Tokyo or no the more yeah I love
third world rugged Africa is my favorite
country or sorry continent
um South Africa is one of my favorite
countries I would say this is the number
one question that I get asked what's
your favorite country and it's hard to
choose that always changes but turkey
was fascinating to me it felt like I was
on another planet
I just had such an adventurous time
there
um that was around my
I don't know in the 20s of countries
that I visited so right now I'm at 31.
there are almost 200 countries in the
world I think there's 190
2 or 191.
so I have a lot to go but I have you
know
touched on a lot I think even when you
travel what's your what's your style of
traveling you like to
it's been all over the place so when I
first started the first country I went
to was Australia and I did five months
there so that was the longest trip I've
ever taken since then yeah so you're
serious back then yeah not five years
not not so much days but five months
yeah and I had such a fun time there I
went to Byron Bay which is this like
hippie little
not little but
um beautiful Town off on the beach and
there's a lot of people doing like
mushrooms and painting drum circles yoga
there's lots of hostels to stay in and I
was very uh broke back then
so I was a pair for a little bit before
a nanny and I would make money doing
that however it was only five dollars an
hour
so
um
I think I made like 500 with that gig
and I ended up flying my ex-boyfriend
out for his birthday and I spent all my
money and I was broke again so I would
just set myself up for failure a lot
financially when I first started
traveling
but then with the transporting gig I
would literally spend almost all of my
money like for the four years that I did
it I would put all my money into
traveling I went to Spain 12 times in
four years I went to countries multiple
times like Egypt twice
um
Morocco twice turkey twice a couple
others and you spend a lot of time when
you're at these locations not really
um it would just depend because I kind
of
was also fixated on my job and making
money at the time so I felt like the
longer I was gone then I was losing out
on money or a boss would be hitting me
up on an app like we would never talk
through text or anything so
they would hit me up and they'd be like
when are you coming back I have an
opportunity for you
so it was like a battle of
being free when I would leave and I was
financially set free eventually but in
the beginning like when I went to
Australia and the first two years of my
travels I didn't have a car in America
um again I would set myself up for
failure financially I would just blow my
money the second I made 500 or a
thousand dollars
and I think after about a year I just
started learning tools
um like on your mindset and figuring out
things about my childhood and it gave me
a lot of clarity within my worth
and I just had a switch in my mindset
and I was like I am worth so much better
than this I do not need to be
hitchhiking all around like a million
like hundreds of millions of people have
a car out there I I can have one too you
know I just simply switched my mindset
and started believing in myself and I
want to say within a week I started just
having so many opportunities come
through financially friendships better
connections with people I'm starting to
love myself
um traveling more so once I switched my
mindset then I was kind of like pulling
myself out of like the roughs which was
couch surfing sleeping on random
people's couches and just drifting
around and sleeping in tents and stuff
like that so
the first year and a half of my travels
was like very rugged and I had checked
around
100 to 200 times
and I would meet I mean it was on The
Daily so sometimes I would hitchhike
three times in one day just to go to
down the street to the grocery store
um but I made a lot of connections
through that but obviously it's super
dangerous and a lot of the things that I
talk about and what I'm gonna say I do
not advise a lot of people to do it's
not for everybody it's just things that
I felt was right in the moment and
sometimes I look back on them and I
think they're very stupid and just being
careless
but I would switch into different modes
and sometimes just be in my Carefree
element so finding the balance of like
careless and carefree has been a huge
challenge for me in my 20s
and
um it sounds like you like Adventure I
love it yeah so like the tell me about
your experience in Turkey
um so
I got there and I was in Spain this was
actually right after
I got out of jail so in the first
interview I explained that I went to
jail for four days after getting busted
with uh having pounds in the back of my
trunk
and
luckily the people I was working for the
bond was a hundred and thirty two
thousand dollars and they bailed me out
so I got it out fast money talks when
you're in jail
um and in a lot of situations in life
so I was bailed out and
they asked for my passport when I left
it was the it was the the Bales or the
bondsman he asked if he could have my
passport and I just lied and I was like
oh I don't have it on me and he's like
okay that's fine well I actually had a
ticket out to Barcelona for three days
later
um because I would have my trips planned
a little bit in advance and
because well I don't want to confuse
anybody so I was on the road driving to
Utah and I had all this weed in my trunk
and I was gonna get paid maybe 10 or 15
000 for it so my plan was to fly to
Barcelona after and spend some time
there but on the way to Utah I got
pulled over I spent four days in jail
and I got out not thinking that I would
make this trip whatsoever I just let it
go I was like obviously I'm in jail I'm
not going to make this trip but I got
out with three days to spare I had a
couple people in Utah that still owed me
money I had enough money to get my truck
out of the tow yard
and it had all my belongings in there so
I went to Utah picked up the cash that I
was owed came back to California just in
time to catch my flight out to Barcelona
like that day it was it was just like go
go go go go fresh out of jail
so me and my friends
um we ended up taking a little bit of
mushrooms and because at this point I
was just like wow I I can't believe I'm
out of jail right now I'm just gonna
live life the fullest and I enjoy taking
some plant medicine here and there
and so I caught this flight to Barcelona
and I had maybe four thousand dollars to
my name and I had eight weeks before I
had to show up to court
so I decided that I was gonna spend
seven of the eight weeks just traveling
but I only had a ticket to Spain
and then I saw that the economy crashed
in turkey and the ticket was only forty
dollars to get to Turkey from Barcelona
so I took a flight to Turkey into
Istanbul
and it was crazy it was like the dollar
for every dollar it was one to twelve so
that's essentially like getting twelve
dollars for every dollar
where as normally it's one to four
so I went there and I was completely
basically rich like I was able to stay
in luxury
hotels that we would spend 500 on in
America for twenty dollars it was really
nice
so my first place that I went to was a
place called pamukule and it's the
Cleopatra bathing pools and that is so
beautiful if you guys ever go to Turkey
that's one of my favorite places I've
ever been to
um
and then I went to a place called
Cappadocia some people pronounce it a
little different but it's basically this
town that is it looks like a sunken in
City
and it has these huge rocks kind of like
Joshua Tree
um which I feel like a lot of people
have been to but there's these huge
rocks and they carved out caves in them
and they built a whole underground city
because there was a war back in the 70s
so people were hiding underground so now
in modern day you'll go to Cappadocia
and it already feels like very again out
of this world
and you'll see like boards covered up in
the streets and that's because under
there's holes and the holes go down like
10 feet or however far down because it's
a whole city underground and you can
take tours
but when I got there I went to this
carpet shop
and it's the biggest carpet shop in
Turkey
I met the gentleman who owned it and he
said there's 70 000 carpets here and
there was 70 rooms of carpet some of
them lead you outside to the big rocks
and all these colors and they're so
beautiful so he was giving me a lesson
on the carpets and he showed me the
symbols and how to read
which I had no idea that you can read
carpets so I pulled out a carpet and he
said try to read this since I just
taught you the symbols and I was like oh
it's it's about a woman who's a widow
and she climbed up a mountain something
with a goat like you can read it like a
story
um so we were pulling out different
carpets and he was like yeah this
gentleman worked on this carpet for six
months he knew just by the textiles and
the carpets all the hand woven ones
So after talking with him for like a 45
minutes or so and he has a servant bring
him like an ashtray
um or some tea for us stuff like that
and the servants just always standing
there ready to
serve us
and he told me he was like I really like
you I would love if you started a carpet
shop in LA or help us with our online
because he was very old he was in his
90s he said I'll know I'll be passing on
soon but he was like I want to fix you
up with or hook you up with my grandson
so we he tried to like set us up in this
random carpet room
and his grandson was only 18 and I was
26 at the time
and I obviously knew like nothing was
going to come about it
but I thought it was just fun in the
moment so I was talking to him and I
asked the grandson
I said what's the craziest thing that's
happened in this town and he told me
about a week ago there was a man that
stood on one of those boards that I was
telling you guys about
and it the board cracked and he fell in
and I guess there was water at the
bottom and the man drowned
and I was like oh my gosh that's so sad
and the boy was telling me how it's
affected the whole town because besides
the tourists there's a lot of people but
the locals there's
um you know it's a small net community
so I asked him
um he told me that I was the owner of a
hotel and I said what's the hotel and he
said the shoe the shoestring hotel and I
looked at him and I was like oh my gosh
that's the hotel I'm staying at
so we kind of just ended our
conversation I went back to my hotel
and I was outside
and I saw this lady and she asked me if
I had a lighter
and I did at the time so I gave it to
her
and she we kind of like sat together
because I I don't really smoke
cigarettes but I did kind of just as a
social thing back then so we were
smoking a cigarette together and within
a few a few minutes she said that her
dad just died and that it was really
hard for her
and I realized that that was the
daughter of the man who obviously just
died
so she told me that she was supposed to
get married a couple days ago but her
father passed away and she was like I
just really want to have like a wild
night but it's against my religion if my
family sees me drinking I'll be
kind of like
um banned from the family or just looked
down upon
so she she had like all these new cars
her dad owned 10 hotels she told me that
she's become a millionaire overnight and
she has to run the hotels and it was
just a lot like her phone was going off
constantly and she's like I just can't
handle this I want to get away and she's
like I love Americans I would love to
take you on an adventure so we got some
wine and we went up to the part of town
where you can Overlook and see the
sunken city
and we were drinking and it was really
fun getting to know each other and I
love getting
to new places and getting to know the
locals
um and as we're drinking I look up and I
see a shooting star
and then I see another one and another
one and we're both looking up and the
sky is just going off and there is a
meteor shower
and it was one of the most magical
moments of my life it was so incredible
and stuff like that just makes traveling
for me so worth it I got to meet locals
I was having a good time I met the carp
the owner of the carpet the biggest
carpet store in Turkey
just like reputable amazing people out
there and just hearing their stories
um
and those are this story is like a lot
more lighter than some of the other ones
I've been on because being a lone girl
is a huge Challenge and people try to
rip you off all day long no matter who
you are especially as an American they
hear your accent you're in a third world
country they're just ready to rip you
off so that started to get to me
and you kind of have to manipulate
people back in a way which is crazy but
I'm sure you know being out here on the
streets sure you do have to be
manipulative sometimes
um and you have to think fast and I put
myself out there
and what happened in turkey again is
super magical but there's places I've
been like South Africa and Johannesburg
and one day I'm with the beautiful
giraffes and elephants and I could see
tigers a little bit of ways
stuff like that and then the next day
um you could be like chased in the
streets like what happened to me and in
that particular situation
I was trying to get a taxi and I called
an Uber
and there's a huge war going on with the
taxis and Uber drivers in Johannesburg
and other parts in Africa
um and they're just ruthless like
they'll come up with baseball bats and
Bash the Uber drivers windows and throw
fire into their car and I heard these
stories time after time I had so many
people telling me not to go to
Johannesburg when I was in Cape Town
which is uh a major city I think it's
the capital actually of South Africa so
people all day long when I travel tell
me don't go here don't go there and
usually they're correct about the
dangerous parts of it but I choose to go
anyways because I'm on my own adventure
and
I like the thrill of it and I don't want
to just go to a place that's super cool
I mean sometimes but like you said do I
like Paris and places like that that's
not my number one place to choose
I want a thrilling adventure so
you'll go to poor places as well right
yeah yeah
even through Africa yeah
um parts of Johannesburg were very poor
so that's where I did
um work with scada Stan and the kids
none of them had shoes
if they did they had they were barely
hanging on
um and I came with toys and just like
pencils and pens and crayons and stuff
like that and they were all over it like
so happy whereas here kids wouldn't I
mean I don't think they would really be
that grateful these kids were lit up you
can give them
this anything and they will light up and
that's my favorite thing to do
um I'm realizing that it's obviously not
just in third world countries That's
Where It's The Most Extreme but in our
own country
there's extremes too
um what really
hits my heart the hardest is the foster
care system
and I do maybe wanna I can do like a
quick
and depth of my childhood
because it's a pretty essential part of
obviously who I am but my adulthood
um and once I've found out the truth of
my childhood it put so much together as
far as why I've traveled so much like it
just makes sense
so I was told that from age birth until
23 years old I was told that my
grandparents adopted me and they took me
in since day one and everything was good
since then
and that's it
but I found out the truth when I came to
visit my mom
um when I was 23 I moved to I moved to
California when I was 21 and a few years
later I met up with my mom she lives out
here in San Francisco
and I wanted to know more about her
since I didn't get to see her throughout
my childhood
once I saw her some terrible things
happened
um and it's a
it's an ongoing thing that she tries to
harm my family and me she's just
aggressive person because she got into a
bicycle accident when she was 13. a
motorcycle hit her on her bike and she
fell off and she had to have brain
surgery so she's very off emotionally
mentally
and she wasn't able to raise me
so I knew that part
but I did not know that she tried to
raise me for eight months
because like I said I thought that my
grandparents had me since day one so my
mom tried to raise me until eight months
and I guess she would do a lot of
questionable things like leave me in the
bathtub and if I was crying she would
like shake me or just throw me down
stuff like that
and one day she decided that she
couldn't handle it anymore and she was
living with my grandparents her parents
so she put me into an adoption facility
and she didn't tell anybody and she took
off with my dad
and she came to the West Coast
and my grandparents were really really
upset because they
I was in their home for eight months so
they grew an attachment to me so they
did everything they could they asked her
can you please let us know this adoption
agency that she's at and my mom just cut
them off
while my grandparents ended up finding
me two weeks later and by then I already
had a family that wanted to adopt me and
they went through the process and
everything
so my grandparents asked if they could
have me back and they said if if they
give them twenty thousand dollars
the family that wanted to adopt me so my
grandparents took out a loan they got me
back
and
I guess my mom found out and she had
called the police and said that my
grandpa was molesting me which was not
true
so my grandpa was thrown in jail this
was back in the 90s so they just acted
on it he was thrown in jail and I was
taken out to foster care
and then I guess it was six weeks that
my grandma was by herself in the home my
grandpa was in jail I was in foster care
until they could prove it wrong and then
my grandpa was released and I was
brought back into their family into
their arms and they raised me ever since
and they've been super worried about me
um and it kind of all just made sense to
me after I found that out because
I went from
my mom's arms to a random family for two
weeks then back to my grandparents
then into another random family and then
back to my grandparents in a matter
under a year so a matter of 11 months or
so so that's five different families and
the first two years of your life
you need to be nurtured the most
um most people are with the same mother
if not maybe they get adopted so that's
two but I was with five
so I think it made me super adaptable
and that's why I'm able to talk to so
many people I'm able to go off on the
streets and make friends everywhere I go
I'm able to just travel to new countries
it's really not for everybody but it's
instilled in me
and it's actually hard for me to ground
because of that
um which is okay I just realized it's my
path and everybody has a crazy story and
I like sharing mine because others can
relate I also have not to like lay
everything on but I have health problems
I'm a type 1 diabetic
so it's been a real struggle on my
travels I've been in the hospital a
couple times one time in Morocco
and being in a third world countries
hospital is really scary they don't have
a lot of resources the communication is
completely off I don't know what they're
you know putting in my body stuff like
that so
um diabetes is no joke and I've been
imbalanced with it many times but I
don't let it control me anymore so
that's great but I just wanted to say
that because again it's relatable
um
but yeah even though like I don't want
to just make traveling sound like it's
all beautiful and pretty because the
pictures that are shown online it's it's
hard it's rough like just because you
have money sometimes doesn't mean that
it's all obstacle free
um but it became an addiction of mine
and I'm so happy that I was able to
go to all the countries that I went to
what have you learned because you know
I've I've seen people who have never
traveled anywhere outside of their
like some of the people in Appalachia
have never left their their little
city or county
um
and I've met people who have been all
over the world and
clearly the people who have traveled
have learned things about living and
life and people in general that
only travel can can teach you what what
kind of stuff have you learned I learned
so much wisdom from it
um I mean obviously there's many things
that I learned but the top I'll give you
top maybe three things uh so the wisdom
aspect I I believe that I was born
street smart but living in Indiana I
think 95 of the kids when we graduated
they all said I'm going to college I'm
going to college and I was one that said
I don't want to go to college I want to
travel and people would call me dumb or
tell me you have to go
I didn't really hear that from my mom
and dad since it was just my grandma she
wasn't really like crazy on me like that
but it was just nice to know that I did
not have to go to college to be smart I
am street smart and I learned so much
more wisdom that I ever think I could
have just by studying from a book I got
to study with my eyes with all my senses
with different tastes and the food and
different languages I picked up on I
learned a little bit of Sanskrit so
they're like mantras in India and for me
when I go off into crazy elements it
makes me feel protected it's kind of
like saying affirmation
sentences
um like saying I am protected I am
protected
but for me the Sanskrit is such a high
vibrational language
I'll say one of them for you it's Jai
Shri Krishna jaitanya prabunich
and that's just my personal it's like an
invocation to all the gods and goddesses
in India or most of them
um and it just makes me feel so
protected
so that's one fun thing that I learned
um
personally I learned and every time I
say this
a lot of older generational people say
that the young never learned this so
let's change that
and it is to help people super simple
advice but if you see someone struggling
if you they need the door open if they
need help packing their groceries in
their car the elderly the young children
whatever that is just go so far and it's
so silly that it took me to travel the
world to know that but
it is what it is and once I learned that
it made my life so much more
um fulfilling
and I love doing that everywhere I go so
again it's really basic but it changes
people's days and it helps with your
good karma too it does I I've let you
have one more to share it right so I'm
interrupting you but no you're gonna
don't lose your point
um but after interviewing so many people
the people who have been through the
hardest struggles and
have maybe learned the the most valuable
lessons in life have all set come up
they've all come back to me with the
same lesson which is it's important to
be of service to others
that's true yeah and that's another
thing when traveling in India that's
like one of their their religion
um they have a couple different
religions but they all say active
service to others is why like a huge
essential part of why we're living here
it's not all about us and I see that all
the time a lot of the times the lessons
I learn are from seeing the opposite
either myself act or other people act in
the opposite manner so people acting
like they're the only person around
and I just experienced that at the
airport the other day a lady was getting
off the bus and I was getting on and I I
had to like stand out of the way for her
to get off she doesn't even look at me
but if it were me I would be like oh
thank you just a little thing and then
she's getting off her huge luggage and
she like knocks me with her luggage and
she doesn't even act like I was there or
she did it she didn't look at me she
didn't say anything I was like excuse
you
and she didn't say anything after that
and I'm just like oh my gosh there's
really people out here
that believe they're the only ones
it's just crazy to me so by seeing
people that act like that it makes me
want to be the opposite
um and I could tell like by the way she
dressed and everything it was like a
wealth thing like she just
money got to her head or something but
it's just really silly so
the third one I mentioned I believe in
the last and the first interview but
it's just uh to be humble because
you know I don't ever want to come off
as I'm bragging I am so so so so so so
so so grateful of all the things I've
been through I am very privileged
um
that was a comment that I got in the
first video white privileged I'm
actually half Mexican and then I just
found out um through my brother he took
a 23andMe test but we are Cherokee
Indian
so
we can drop the white privilege part and
I will admit I am very privileged but so
are you guys because you're either on a
computer a tablet a cell phone watching
this and that is a privilege in itself
there's a lot of people out there that
don't have that they don't even barely
have water every day we are so
privileged what is the poorest part of
the world you've seen
parts of India yeah yeah they have
some I went to vrindavan India it's uh
so you fly into New Delhi
and then it's a three hour drive down
south and on the way there was parts
that we stopped in like little Villages
and there's just dead rotting dogs
everywhere the the trash was overfilled
you couldn't even tell if people were
sleeping or if they were dead honestly
um it was just their way of life but I
couldn't believe how many dead rotting
animals there were everywhere and it
wasn't just a fresh dead dog like you
could see the bones coming out and it
had been you know they sit there and
just no trash gets picked up including
people and animals it's pretty hardcore
so that was crazy to me where what's
what's been your experience where you've
seen the kindest people oh
um
the most hospitable people to me have
been in Turkey
um I would be walking the streets by
myself and there would be people men
women
all ages they would come outside or be
sitting on their deck and they would
offer me tea
and I would take up a lot of the offers
if I felt safe I would just sit on their
deck and they thought I was from Turkey
like just a citizen walking
um and then they heard I had an accent
and most of them would speak English
something really cool too there's other
places that are very kind in the world
like all over but that was just my first
thought
with not knowing any other language
primarily
besides English I got by a lot off-body
language which was really cool when I
was in the pyramids in Giza in Egypt I
so I had my camera with me
and there was a Guardsman at the bottom
of uh so the biggest pyramid it's uh
King Khufu the Pharaoh his tomb is up
there well there's like conspiracy
theories that it's not up there anymore
but whatever
um
so I wanted to go up inside the pyramid
which I didn't know you could even go
inside sorry if I spoiled that for
anybody but there's a Guardsman at the
bottom and you're not allowed to bring
any uh cameras in so he asked if he
could hold my camera but I didn't really
trust him my camera was really expensive
so I decided to talk to him for a little
bit this is what I would do a lot of
times like you have to sacrifice your
time for your protection sometimes so
by me talking to this man spending 10 15
minutes seeing if I trust him with my
camera or if he's just gonna run off
that's going to save me you know getting
a new camera or something like that
so I ended up talking with him he was
really cool he said that he's been on
the grounds every day since he was a
child
and it was really nice to speak to such
a
grounded local there I mean living in
the pyramids and being there every
single day that was his devotion
and I let him or he watched my camera
and I went up and I was walking up the
stairs and it was getting really really
hot it was already like 100 degrees this
was in May
um and temperatures reach in the summer
time like 1 20 every day so
um I was going up the stairs and I see
all these people walking down and
they're just like sweating like super
intensely and I thought it was crazy how
many people were walking down
and then I get up to the top and when I
reach the top inside the the area of the
um the pyramid
there's only one person there and it's a
Guardsman and I was so confused I was
like what like all these people just
walked down the stairs there was like a
hundred people that walked down there's
a lot of stairs too
and the Guardsmen didn't speak English
he spoke Arabic so we were talking with
body language and I've never got so far
off body language it was so cool he was
telling me about the just how it was
khufu's tomb here and he he had me he
just went like this closed your eyes he
walked me over to the tomb he had me put
my hands over the tomb and in that
moment it was I'm gonna lose some people
here
but I saw a vision and it was it went
all the way back like this is only for
two seconds but with my hands over the
vision went all the way back of my whole
entire life and then it like flashed
forward and it just showed me like
immense happiness and travel but it was
only two seconds and it startled me so I
like went back and I feel like I just
had like a intense Vision in the
pyramids
um which was incredible like and I
wasn't on anything I was completely
sober but it felt like some kind of like
psychedelic vision
and I knew in that moment I was done I
only needed to be up there for one
minute and I thanked the Guardsmen I
walked back down and all these people
were rushing up and I was like whoa like
that's so crazy how did I just end up
there by myself with the Guardsmen so I
get to the bottom to get my camera the
man that watched my camera asked me what
happened or how my experience was and I
told him
and the look on his face he was like
he's like oh my gosh he's like he's like
it is 12 p.m on a
um you know a spring day he's like all
these tourists here he's like you're
telling me that you were the only one up
there he's like that only happens to me
at 5am like very early hours in the
morning before all the tourists he's
like that never happens like you are so
lucky you are so guided to have that
moment and it really did it feels like I
went up there and like all the people
left just for me to have that vision for
whatever reason
so like between that and like the meteor
shower stuff like that just makes
traveling so magical and unexpected
and I get that some of these stories are
unbelievable because if I didn't travel
and get out there I would think people
are crazy for certain things but I
learned so much from with my own eyes
seeing stuff like that like seeing a
meteor shower I realize now how many
stars actually go off
and that magic is in the air in Egypt
and I believe in ghosts now because I've
had crazy ghost experiences but if I
didn't have them then I wouldn't believe
in this so I get why people think it's
just crazy sometimes but there's so much
out there we live in such a vast magical
world so
yeah what did you learned about people
of all your troubles
um you're seeing all kinds of people all
kinds of different yeah I've met
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people all these different cultures what
have you learned about humans in general
yeah and I put myself out there so you
meet even more
so I would say majority of people are
very closed off
but
I think someone like you and me one of
our gifts is people open up to us easily
like since I was a kid
I would have people tell me these crazy
things even my grandma was kind of
alarmed sometimes when we were in the
store she's she'd be like why did that
person just tell you so much information
or now that I own a jewelry business and
it's right off the beach
um I have so many people walk up to me
and they'll tell me about their son that
just died in an accident or like their
problems with this and that and they'll
start crying and I just met them and
it's only 10 minutes into a conversation
so to have that I feel like as a gift
because people feel comfortable with you
and they open up so I know that I have
that and when I go around the world
people are constantly opening up to me
but I realized with other friends that
express it like people aren't like that
all the time people are very like
guarded and
um I have to open up to be opened up to
you know
um if I put up a wall which I can do
that and I have on my travels I'm not
just this open book all the time
um especially the way I dress like I
respect each culture
um even in the weed industry when I was
working I'd always have hoodies on I
looked like you wouldn't even recognize
me I looked like a different person I
had my hair back all the time it feels
so good to be able to dress how I want
to and just be myself completely
um
but people are all sorts I wouldn't even
say you can put a specific category
because there's so many different types
of people that
were just amazing
um I'm sure you'd agree that it's
important to be
open-minded and adventurous and just
open to doing something crazy yeah
travel right open to doing something
crazy I love
um it might sound cheesy but I just love
lifting others up because I can see that
like I know that I have a strong light
in me and I just go around and smile at
people and it changes people's days it
changes my day so why not it's like a
win-win both sides so I tell people they
look beautiful and like even if they
have like some crazy hair and they look
like they haven't showered if they have
a beautiful smile or a beautiful Aura
when I'm walking in the streets going
through these countries I'll be like oh
you're beautiful Bonita like just you
know it makes life so much more fun so
I'm walking around with my head up
looking at the structures and just
having a great time like how could I not
it sounds like you've already had the
kind of experiences I have which is when
you
try to get to know one person you get to
know the whole country yeah
truly they open up to you yeah and it's
hard at first because you go through a
moment like what am I doing why am I
here
like certain countries I'm just like I'm
really out here I'm all by myself like
what the heck am I doing I never feel
lost though I've been called that by
people but I never had a sense of like
feeling lost sometimes I'm just like how
did I end up here but I know there's a
reason and then once I get a little bit
established and maybe I'll go around the
same block two three times or go to the
same coffee shop and get to know one
person there and that person introduces
me to someone else or you know
um and how is how is traveling the world
changed the way you live when you're at
home
um
so
it put in through perspective that
so many people told me not to go certain
places
and I never had a thought of listening
to them tell me what to do I don't let
people tell me what to do
unless I'm influenced by them you know
but most of the time if someone's trying
to tell me what to do I'm just like no
like I'm gonna go do what I want to do
and
I realized that these people are
speaking out of fear but
they're living in America and for me the
worst things that have ever happened to
me have been in America
like getting robbed I've gotten my car
broken into these are separate occasions
so car broken into in Portland I got
robbed in Chicago and I got a gun put to
my head in Munster Indiana and that's my
hometown so these are terrible things to
happen
and it made me realize I'm never ever
going to be in fear of leaving the
country because I'm living so freely out
there and when I come back like it
doesn't matter where you are anything
can happen so I guess it just taught me
to live the fullest and
um not to be scared because for me the
scariest place is here not overseas or
anything
all right Lauren thank you for coming
back and telling us about your travels
yeah it's been so fun you live an
interesting life thank you I think uh
you figured out at a very young age what
a lot of us could could apply to our
lives and
try we try to be open-minded and
adventurous but
but you're doing it thank you so much
yeah and I'm going to document more
thanks for inspiring me too yeah I've
been talking to Lauren
yeah off camera about about what you
should be doing with her with her
fascination of travel yes so he inspired
me to start a YouTube channel
I never thought I would be
um comfortable enough to be on camera or
anything so just opening up about my
story has helped me so much just like
release I mean I had a lot to say
especially the first time
um and I never
thought people like people think it's
unbelievable so I never even realized
that that's what I've been living so
it's helped me so much your whole life
is an adventure yes and you're so young
yet so thank you thank you Lauren
sweet